hi there i'm craig and i'm a developer
in this course
we're going to explore the wonderful
world of web hooks
understanding the concepts behind web
hooks will open up a new and powerful
world of possibilities
for your projects and your applications
there are infinite opportunities
available for you to connect
applications that you know
and love together to create new
experiences for both you
and your users now in order for you to
get the most out of this course
i'd love it if you had a basic
understanding of how to access
web-based apis now if you don't yet no
worries
i've attached to this video some
teachers notes i've listed some ways for
you to gain that experience there
now even if you've already met the
prerequisites
can you please take a minute and locate
the teachers notes throughout the course
i'm going to refer to them
in those notes i'll drop additional
information and share places where you
can learn more about what we're chatting
about
i'll also use those notes to keep you
updated on anything that might have
changed from
my right now when i'm filming this
course to your right now
whenever you're watching this in the
future i hope things are going good for
you in the future
but while we're talking about your
future let's chat a bit about what you
can expect from this course
we're going to first talk about the
high-level concepts of webhooks where
they come from
when and why you might want to use them
and i'll walk you through some inspiring
solutions that you can build
without writing any code whatsoever
you're going to love it pretty sure
you're going to get hooked
and after you get web hooked we'll move
from a no code solution to explore some
more low code solutions
we are going to explore events that
github sends out when activity happens
on their site
now no worries if you haven't had any
previous experience with the code
sharing site github we'll start from the
very beginning and get you up and
running quickly
we'll also then spin up a serverless
function using a free platform named
netlify and will handle or do something
with
the event data that comes from github if
you haven't used serverless technology
before
again don't fret we'll walk through what
that means and how to take advantage of
its power
now all the code in this course will
walk through together you'll have access
to
all of the completed code after we've
got a good grasp on the basics
we'll make use of webhooks to build an
entire telephone based
application we'll build from start to
finish an entire idea capturing and text
transcription service
the application will lean completely on
web hooks for workflow management
all done with shockingly few lines of
code
this course is going to deal with
consuming events passed to our web hooks
now that is to say we won't be writing
code that
sends information to register web hooks
check the teacher's notes if you're
interested in learning more about
how to send web hook events i am
super excited to get started with this
course but there's just
one more thing that i'd like to talk
about with future you
if at any time you need me to pause or
slow down
remember you're in a video based course
take advantage of that i am more than
happy to repeat myself if you missed
something
speed me up slow me down flip on the
closed captions make yourself at home
these days i know i've gotten pretty bad
about the way that i consume video
content i just watch
and watch and then i watch some more
well it turns out that education
doesn't really work too well with
binging like that if you feel like
you're starting to zone out
like i did through the endless seasons
of survivor
it's time for a break i'm not here to
make friends
i've put some deliberate stopping points
in this course and i'll do my best to
remind you to take a break
breaks are important they're super
critical for your learning you need to
let things sink in
and i want you to get the most out of
our time together
there we go we got all that housekeeping
stuff all covered
i'm sure you were starting to get like
my kids do on a long drive and they're
like dad are we there yet
actually that's a pretty good example
for where a web hook works
wonderfully my kids continually ask me
that question
over and over again are we there yet
they keep making that request
the same one over and over pulling me
directly
to see if we've arrived at our
destination now typically
my response is i'll tell you when we get
there
more or less what i'm promising is that
when we get there i will broadcast our
arrival status when that approach works
like when my kids actually decide to
subscribe to my status updates
i can tell you that it makes things a
lot easier on the whole
car i don't get overloaded and they can
relax they just sit there
and wait for my update so much more
efficient
so i guess what i'm attempting to
broadcast to you now is
we're here we've arrived at the start of
the course
now i think the best place to start our
journey is to explore a concept
often present in application development
events
let's get started an event in code is a
defined action or occurrence
now these events are typically exposed
to us software developers
so that we can write code that runs
specifically when one of these actions
or occurrences happen
the first type of event that i'd like to
talk about is one that is caused by the
user of your application
let's think about a button on a web page
this
button will trigger an event when it is
clicked by a user
you can optionally write some code that
will run and
only run when that event occurs you do
this by adding or
registering what is known as an event
listener
you write code also referred to as a
handler
used to handle the specific event in
this case
click this code will only run when that
event
happens this is called event driven
programming in this example
it's used to empower you to not have to
write code that continually
checks to see if the button is being
pressed just like the kids in the car
it isn't very efficient for you to write
code asking
hey button are you clicked yet are you
clicked yet
now how about now are you clicked the
click of it is just one of many events
that web pages allow for listening to
check the teachers notes for more
browser-based event examples
similar in concept to a user-generated
event is what is known as a life cycle
event
life cycle events are typically exposed
to us via application libraries or
frameworks
you can think of application libraries
and frameworks as tools
that help us rapidly develop our
applications these libraries do this
by providing repeatable ways for us to
write our applications
for example these libraries allow us
developers to customize various parts of
the application
at specific times in specific
contexts they allow us to hook into
specific lifecycle events
for instance when you're building a web
application these days you're almost
certainly using a front-end application
library
one of the main benefits that these
libraries give you is the ability to
write code for only your specific needs
a great example is you can write code
once your component has been loaded on
the screen
this load is a life cycle event usually
this looks something like has been
loaded what's happening here is what is
known as
inversion of control now this is because
the control
is being handed to you the developer
from the application
at exactly the right time the library
does its magic
it prepares your component it then
renders it out to the screen
and when it's loaded on the page it
calls the code
that you wired up to your has been
loaded hook
and that abstraction is super nice you
don't call the function yourself
the library actually calls your function
when it's ready
this inversion of control pattern is
also often referred to as the hollywood
principle
in hollywood casting directors usually
tell the person auditioning
don't call us we'll call you now this is
because
if they didn't the actor would just keep
calling them
yeah i was just in there auditioning i'm
pretty sure i got the part i did really
good
weird they hung up i guess i'll call
back no i was the the older guy
i was just wondering when should i come
in for my my wardrobe fitting
hello weird they disconnected i guess
i'll try that again
again like my kids these actors are
totally going to overload these
directors with their needy questions
if they were allowed to call the
director and check for their approval
they do it all the time
that hollywood principle abstraction
allows the actor
to not need to understand the entire
process that hollywood directors are
going through
the directors do whatever it is that
directors do
think it involves tall chairs and
megaphones and snacks
definitely snacks the point is only when
the directors make their decision do
they call to inform the actor
these patterns of event handlers and
life cycle hooks have
really proven useful in helping
developers to build extensible
applications
and the good news is that this powerful
abstraction can also span across
entirely different applications over the
internet
by using what is known as tada
a web hook now that we've got a light
understanding of the basics of event
handlers and hooks
let's run through a quick refresher of
how to use an api
have you heard of iot the internet of
things
well this here is a thing
well not this adorable slash weird
dog lamp thing but the actual light bulb
itself
it's what is known as a smart bulb now
i've got an
app on my phone which lets me
turn on the light pretty cool right
i mean don't get me wrong a plain old
light bulb is pretty amazing when you
think about it
when i turn on the light switch it
allows power to come to the bulb and it
lights up
that's cool but that's me doing it i'm
turning it on
and in reality it's not much different
with me using an application on my phone
is it
i'm telling it to turn on i can also
even change the color but even that
i'm saying to make the light green and
i'm telling it to do it when i click
now what makes these light bulbs really
shine
that's a dad joke and tend to do that
sorry about that one
but what makes these light bulbs really
smart is that they can be controlled by
external events
like for instance i can make it so the
bulb turns on
at sundown i can even set up a schedule
so that it gets darker
the closer it comes to my bedtime making
me feel sleepier
because my lights are outsmarting me in
fact
you've probably seen it there's a whole
industry around smart
homes so many products all sorts
revolving around the house being smarter
than what's going on around it
the industry saw incredible growth over
the past couple of years
now the way this particular light bulb
works is that
i define a schedule of how i want it to
behave
the light bulb isn't sitting there
asking my schedule over and over again
if it's time to turn on
there's an external program that's
running and when my defined time occurs
it sends the request to the bulb to turn
on it's almost as if the sun said to my
light bulb
don't call us kid we'll call you at
sunset
turn on the lights and it does just like
i did when i click my phone it sends the
same message
to the light bulb to turn on and in fact
in this particular example
it quite literally is as if i did it
using the phone
this light bulb is actually connected to
the internet with an
exposed api i can control it via an api
from my computer here so this here is
postman
if you haven't seen this tool before you
should totally check it out i
absolutely love it for exploring apis
now the api that i'm exploring here
is from lifx or lightfx
the company that produces my light bulb
now you'll see here that i can change
the values
and you'll notice here that it's a put
puts can be used to explain changing a
particular
property of the resource and not
replacing all of them
in this case i'm going to send a put
request
so i'm going to send a put request to my
lite
this api uses a bearer token to
authenticate and i've got that all set
up
and you can see here that i am changing
the color to red
now i'm going to send a put request
to this specific bulb
so i'm going to click this here
and boom it's red
and that's pretty cool isn't it i can
use this code
to turn this light off and on and we
already know that
just letting this light turn off and on
with regards to the sun has made it
labeled
smart when the sun goes down turn on
sure that's pretty smart but i bet us
being able to control it via code might
make this thing labeled a
genius i mean if you think about it it's
like
when anything like anything at all that
i can dream up happens
turn it on even better we
saw that we can change the color i can
make this turn green when i have a new
email
or flash different colors when someone
comments on a youtube video
or i'm sure if i was into sports i bet
it i would love if this blinked my
team's colors when they scored a point
go teams sports
what if i use this for an on air light
for like when i was in
a video conference so my kids knew
not to come barging in on my call they'd
see
this rudolph the red-nosed dog lamp
thing was on
and they'd know that i was on a call and
when it was done i could turn it off
genius i tell you genius now
whoa i actually beat that like right now
but wait a second would that mean that
i'd have to write a program that just
sat there and
checked all those situations like keep
checking the sports scores and keep
checking my email inbox
like for that video call example if i
think about it what it feels like to me
is that i'd have to write some code to
continually check and see if i was on a
video call
and it doesn't feel very efficient at
all does it
in fact that feels an awful lot like my
kids asking if we were there yet
but what if a video call starting was
considered an event
and what if i was able to write some
code to handle that video call started
event
i'd be able to in that handling code
turn on the light just just like we did
in the code
i guess that would mean i'd have to
write some sort of plug-in for my video
conferencing software if i wanted to
share it
i'd like have to have everybody in the
world install some software if they
wanted to use it
yuck wouldn't it be nice if somehow that
event could trigger outside of the
application to anyone
like over the internet this my friend is
where web hooks come into play
chances are your video conferencing
provider
allows you to listen and handle events
using web hooks
that solution basically already exists
we'll look at web hooks like that one
here in a bit but
do you see how if that event was sent
across the internet
i wouldn't need to write code to
continually poll to see if i was in a
meeting
i can just wait for the video conference
started notification
now my video conferencing provider says
don't call me kid i'll call you
and our handler just says turn on the
light and it
only runs when our provider says hey kid
a video conference started
now i hope that you just had one of
those
light bulb moments and i mean that quite
literally
and figuratively like the type above
your head
i hope that thing just turned on i'd
like to ask you to take a little break
now
i'd like this to sink in for you and one
way to help this all make sense
is for you to pause the video and think
about what we just saw
can i get you to come up with three
ideas of what you might want to do
if you owned the smart bulb everyone has
different needs
and remember quite literally anything
could trigger it
could make it change colors now if
you're having trouble coming up with
ideas check the notes
so really i want you to let your mind
wander
what would you like to have happen to
make this light turn
on it could be literally anything you
can dream up
so let's take a break and when you come
back i'll share some tools that will
give you a lot of inspiration
i'm thinking you'll be pleasantly
surprised you might even be able to
achieve what you dreamed up with just a
couple of clicks
see you in a bit
before the break i asked you to come up
with some ideas to make this
smart light bulb even smarter how'd it
go
did ideas just flow out of your mind
sometimes i find that when i'm told to
dream up anything at all
suddenly i can't i have ideas popping my
mind all the time but the second you
asked me to come up with one like right
on the spot
my mind goes blank and that's a bummer
especially when you're trying to learn a
new technology you want to put into
practice
but you have no real idea where to start
so if that just happened to you
no worries i kind of expected it would
happen and i've got a solution
for that lack of ideas problem and we'll
get to that here in a second
to get there first though let's talk
about a growing movement called
no code don't worry it's not a movement
to abolish coders
no code is the concept that you can and
often should build applications without
actually writing
any code you're given building blocks
and you snap them together
the concept is that the applications we
build are similar enough
that they can be broken down into
reusable parts and
snap together into new formations to
build new
applications it's wonderful for
prototyping and frankly
sometimes you can build exactly what you
were trying to do without writing a
single line of code like no code at all
and i'm talking about some
super impressive stuff e-commerce sites
and integrations with third-party apis
check the notes if you're interested in
diving deeper into this
one of my favorite no code sites has
been around for a
long time even before the no code
movement took off
it's called ifttt which stands for
if this then that it's a no code
solution for exactly what we've been
leading up to
it's an event handler for the internet
if this happens
then do something and there are a
smattering of options that they call
services these are services that expose
events that can happen
and there are a bunch of them from your
location
changed to its snowing to the sun is
setting
you'll also notice that there are other
services here that are web specific
there's an email service that exposes
events like new email received
so you define the service that you want
to use and you choose the specific event
if this and now you choose what happens
when that event
occurs then that these are called
service actions and there are a
different set of services here that
allow you to do
different things so for instance the
company that makes this light bulb i was
using
was called lifx or lifx
and they provide an action service and
it exposes
a bunch of things that i can do with my
light bulb
like change the color and because
i've linked my accounts already i can
choose which of my light bulbs
what color and many other things and
combining the service with an
action like a whole if this then that
combo
is called an applet cool right
so i'm pretty sure that you could build
a couple of applets to create your own
ideas
with just a couple of clicks and
definitely no code
i think that this hashtag no code
movement might be onto something
it's hashtag no joke but now though
what about the situation that we had
where you didn't have an idea
well this is awesome and this is a
developer hack that keeps on giving
sample applications are a wonderful way
to get inspired
and guess what these applets are
shareable
in fact if you go up here to explore
you'll get suggestions but you can also
type what you're looking for so i asked
you to come up with ideas about
lights so let's type that lights so
let's see all the applets surrounding
lights
uh so here we have toggle lights blink
your lights that's nice
disco party for key lights that's
wonderful alexa turn on the lights sorry
if i just triggered your alexa at home
if you have one
turn on my lights blink when your
doorbell rings these are great
all sorts of things now i can enable one
of these for my own account
and when it comes up it asks for my
specific
configuration now you probably noticed
that there were different types of smart
bulbs in there in that list
but that doesn't mean that you can't
take that idea and make it work for your
own use case
do you see the power in that this is
actually a pretty
common pattern in developing software
you take the base code
and you make a copy of it and you make
your changes this is called
forking you fork your new copy and
remember
this is just one of many no code
automation tools
if you're enjoying this way of thinking
i encourage you to look at
zapier they provide similar building
blocks to the complete
same sort of if this happens then do
that you wire up services
to create what they call zaps it's super
fun
and i highly recommend exploring here
too there are lots of inspiring ideas to
be found
zapier makes you happier i just love
that
these no code automation tools go a long
way in making just about anything
possible
but as you can imagine there are going
to be cases
when you're going to want to have more
control you're going to want to write
some specific code that the action
doesn't provide
i'm pretty sure that's why you're here
in fact you want to use
a web hook so let's do that let's
explore how that works
right after a quick break i'd love to
give you some more time to explore
these no code tools and i really want
you to think about these
applets or zaps as an abstraction of the
power of web hooks
oh one thing that might help if you want
to just play around with some actions
there's a smartphone app and it lets you
install buttons on your home screen
just like this like look here i've wired
it up an ifttt button so that when i
click it it turns on the red light
that way roxanne doesn't have to do it
that was a bad one
don't call the joke police on me hope
that one didn't sting too much
check the teacher's notes for more
exploration guidance and please let me
know what you come up with
see you in a bit and when you come back
we'll explore how to capture information
sent from a web hook i think in order to
get the clearest picture
of how web hooks work it will help if we
travel way back
to 2007. it was a time of wearing double
polo shirts so you could pop your collar
twice people wore ugg boots
with shorts and justin timberlake was
actively trying to bring sexy back
and web forms were still a thing it was
a simpler time to gather information
from a user on your website
you'd write an html form and you'd put a
method
on it of post and in the action you'd
put the name of the script
and it's important to remember that the
web is stateless
once this request to generate the page
that the form lives on
the web server job is done the get
request
is over so your user would fill out the
html form with the named fields
and then they'd click a submit button
what the browser does for you in this
case is it takes all the values that
were entered in the form
and it makes a brand new http request
to the url that you specified in the
action attribute
that post request contains the data that
the user entered in an
encoded way and as a developer
you would write a request handler on
your website to capture the information
from this request
and then you'd act on it so again your
browser is making a request
to your server so way back in 2007
a developer by the name of jeff lindsey
made a proposal to use an existing idea
already very present in software design
patterns
he proposed to use the hook model that
we talked about
but instead of locally he suggested to
do it
over the internet and he called it a web
hook
jeff realized that it would be fairly
straightforward for web developers who
were already
very familiar with processing form data
submitted via a post
request what this approach would feel
like to developers is just another
form submission in this case instead of
the user submitting the form
a third party could submit the data the
handler could be written the same way
the developer already knows
the information is pushed to the handler
in that same familiar way
to the developer and everyone wins so
in order for this to work the third
party application
needs to be informed from the developer
where they should post their information
you know the url where that handler
lives and then
when the third party event happens it
posts the information about the event
to that url that app is
definitely embracing the hollywood
principle right don't call us
we'll call you and it took off
for all the reasons that event based
programming wins it's of course
way more efficient to receive a post
request than continuously polling an api
checking for a change instead of are we
there yet are we there yet via
an api the post request sends we're here
so that was 2007. web hooks are now
everywhere and i'm guessing what brought
you to this course
was that you encountered one in the wild
and you weren't exactly sure how to use
it
no worries this happens to everyone the
first time they run across one
it's a bit challenging to understand at
first
the web has changed a lot since 2007 but
the web hook concept here is still
pretty much the same our apps are now
built differently like for instance
we may be using services and instead of
forum post we build our own apis for our
clients to use
and the client posts information to our
api usually not using a form
we developers use web-based apis all the
time to build our applications
you should view web hooks as an
extension of that type of work
this is why sometimes you'll hear
webhooks referred to
as a reverse api it calls you
instead of you calling it when you use
an api
you need to understand the parameters
that it expects
and the reverse is true for web hooks
you need to know what information is
being sent to you
and in what format there is no formal
specification
and any data can be sent to your handler
now these days
our web handlers most likely look a wee
bit different than they did in 2007
technology has evolved some handlers
still accept traditional
form posted data and some of our
handlers accept json posted in the body
for client side the apis that we're
writing right
see the teacher's notes for more on this
you'll find a variety in what web hooks
post to your handlers as well
as a developer writing one of these web
hook handlers it's pretty important that
you understand
how to capture and parse that incoming
data
let's take a look at an existing webhook
implementation
and see if we can't capture the data to
inspect right after
a quick break by now i'm hoping that
you're inspired to
connect unrelated applications together
we've got a good taste
of some powerful concoctions through the
no code solutions of ifttt
and zapier you've seen what's possible
you
understand why you'd want to use events
to trigger actions as opposed to pulling
an api repeatedly
with the what and the why of web hooks
out of the way
i think it's time that we take a deeper
look under the hood
to see how these web hooks are actually
working
i was trying to think of common
applications that all of us developers
are bound to use
and the obvious one to me is github if
you've taken a look at the notes for
this course which
i hope you have then you for sure
already encountered github i've put the
notes and code for this course in a
github
repository or repo github is a social
coding site
it enables you to share your code and
work on projects together
you can submit issues and keep detailed
version history of your software
and you can read documentation it's a
wonderful place to explore when you're
first
learning to code if you don't have an
account yet
i'd love for you to pause the video and
sign up for a free account
quick note i'm going to show off a
little bit of how to use github
i've dropped notes that give a more
detailed tour in the teacher's notes to
learn more
make sure to check it out there's even a
link to a video game that will walk you
through making your
first pull request or a request to make
a change to someone else's code
i know that can feel a little bit
daunting but it doesn't need to
i want it to feel fun for you because
it is after you've got yourself logged
into github
we'll fork my teacher's notes repository
to your account
this will make it all yours now forking
is the process that happens when you see
a repository that you like
and you'd like to explore it and make
your own changes you fork it
and you make it your own you make your
own copy of that repository
now you can always later ask to apply
the changes back to the original
repository
now i want you to fork the repository
because once the repository is all
yours you can specify some web hooks on
it
so here i am on the notes repository for
this class
the links attached in the video i did
want to make a quick note that the
layout might look a little bit different
on the github site as they're constantly
making improvements
now in the off chance that you can't
find what i'm doing because the site has
changed please remember to check the
notes for this specific video
i'll update future you there with what's
different and we'll get back on track
sure glad i used github for this up here
you'll see some
social features so you can star
a repo which is equivalent of a social
media love or thumbs up now
as a developer someone giving you a star
has that same
dopamine hit as alike does the more
stars your repo receives the more likely
it'll be
discovered and here is the fork icon
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
fork this and i'm going to put a copy in
my account
and now you'll see it's copying
everything over
and this is now my own copy
boom just like that pretty freaking fast
right
so note how this repo is mine it's under
my username and you can see where it was
forked
from and now that this repo
is mine you can see that i have a
settings tab
now so i'm going to go ahead i'm going
to click into here and you'll see here
on the left
nav that we have an option for webhooks
awesome let's click into it
webhooks allow external services to be
notified when certain events happen
just like we talked about awesome
totally makes sense
okay so let's add a web hook for
our repo so i'm going to click this add
web hook
button so i was thinking that we should
get
the information when someone stars our
repo
so what we're going to need is a url to
handle that request
do you have one i don't have one so a
quick solution
to capture a web hook just to check
things out is to use what's known as a
mocking
tool one of my favorite ways to mock a
web hook handler is to use a web-based
tool called
b-cepter here let me show you i'm going
to open that up so i'm going to come
here i'm going to make a new tab
we're going to go to b scepter.com
let's make this a little bit bigger and
again
b ceptor might look a little bit
different uh if you come in here so
check the notes if you can't seem to
follow along with what i'm doing
so let's see what am i gonna do i'm
gonna try github event so let's call it
github so basically what you do is you
just
put your name there and you can click
this create endpoint
and now as you can see i have this
github.free.bsepter.com so i'm going to
go ahead i'm going to copy this
i'm going to keep this page open i'm
going to pop back over to my add a web
hook page here
and i'm going to paste that into the
payload url so that that's where it will
be
sent where the information will be sent
and we're going to capture the stars so
i'm just going to push slash stars at
the end here so that i know what that is
and that's the cool thing about bcepter
you can just invent whatever you want
that that route doesn't exist
but it will still catch it all right
let's keep filling out this form
so we have content type that's nice that
github lets you do that we have
a couple options here we can either send
json or form
url encoded so i'm going to choose json
let's do that
and the other nice thing that github
does is they let you choose which events
you would like to trigger the web hook
you can send just the push event that's
when somebody sends
code to your repo or you could say send
me everything but they also let you
select the individual events and we
really only want when someone stars the
repo so let's do that so i'm going to
click that
and i'm going to choose down in here
there is one
for see how many much stuff you can do
you can sure do a lot so i'm going to do
stars so here it says a star is created
or deleted
uh from a repository i'm going to
uncheck pushes
okay so there we go so we just have
stars so anytime somebody starts this
repo
we should get an event cool alright so
i'm going to click add
webhook and now if i go
and star my own repo because i can do
that because i like myself
i'm gonna start and if i head over to
bscepter
you'll see that there was a post to
stars actually there was two because
github posts originally to your link
just to make sure it works
so here is what happened when we start
so i'm going to
click uh click into this here and then
i'm going to click this little
this this little kodi thing looking
thing over here i'm going to click this
because it will help format things
better
and this is what github sent us it's
pretty cool right so it shows you all
the different
information of the repo that was on and
if we scroll down a little bit
farther we can see all things about the
repo all these different uh
rest apis that i can hit to get more
information if i wanted to
this is all about the repo itself and i
think if we get down here a little bit
closer
this is kind of hard to read um in here
but definitely uh
captures exactly what was sent if we
scroll down
wow it's a lot if we scroll down um into
here there we go we can see who sent the
star and we can see who
the user was which
is very nice and it's got more
information it's got the avatar url i'm
gonna actually let's open that up let's
see
let's see what this is
oh look at that dork who liked this repo
and i can use this to figure out uh what
i would like to handle right so this is
a post that was
sent to any url and i can figure out
what i want to handle
i want to go back and show you something
else that's pretty cool in side of
github that not everybody offers that
offers a
web hook but github is pretty great so
i'm going to come back
into our web hook that it exists and it
will show you what
happened right so it will show you the
the deliveries that were made
so if i open this up i can see and this
is actually
more nicely formatted not everything
offers this so it is important
uh to remember bcepter because you're
going to want to catch other web hooks
um and not everybody has this nice
functionality
so again we can see this and we can see
you know
see that dork this door here it's so
nice that github lets you control the
format and actually see the way the data
is presented they really
web hook you up okay
so now that we have a firing web hook
let's see if we can't make use of that
data
right after a quick break we've now got
a web hook that fires when our
repository is
starred and i think we should use that
knowledge to celebrate
and we shouldn't celebrate alone so i
was thinking about another pretty common
developer tool
that you're bound to encounter is some
sort of real-time group chat software
it's very common that you'll end up in a
chat room of sorts now whether that be
slack or microsoft teams or discord
these channels are a great way to stay
up to date with whatever it is that
you're
congregating around it's also a good
place to just hang out and learn
so i was thinking why don't we explore
sending our github data into one of
these chat
platforms we'll make sure that everyone
celebrates when our repo gets started
now i'm going to choose discord but
you'll find that most platforms provide
a similar sort of integration
now like we saw with github we were able
to define a web hook that would fire
when certain events happen
now discord actually allows you to set
up the other site automatically
they set up a webhook handler for you
let's see what that feels like
just a friendly reminder this is
probably going to look a little
different for you
in the future now if you run into any
problems following along
check the teachers notes i'll update you
there with changes
all right so if you don't already have
discord it's a pretty quick setup and
i've included
installation instructions in the notes
go ahead and pause me and get it all set
up
this here is my current discord i've got
some learning channels set up so
here's the free code camp and there's
twilio quest there's the coding den
all great learning communities
if you're looking for extra places to
hang out and learn to code check out the
teachers notes
so i'm going to go ahead i'm going to
make my own brand new server by clicking
the plus
button and i am going to say create a
new server and
invite your friends i'm going to do that
let's go ahead i'm going to call this
exploration
and we can get rid of this later uh
totally
fine and i'm gonna click create
uh and it's gonna say um invite your
friends
i'm just gonna go ahead and close this
i've got friends i promise i got friends
so what's really nice about each one of
these
discord channels so like this is where
you could come and uh talk right so you
could talk in these channels
each one of them has this little icon
here and because we own this
server we can uh edit the webhook so
let's go in here
i'm going to click on this integrations
over here on the left
and you'll see here there's this web
hooks i'm going to choose
create webhook and let's see webhooks
are a simple way to post messages from
other apps and websites into discord
using internet magic
i agree they are pretty magical aren't
they
let's make some magic oh and here it
came up with a suggested name
captain hook what a great dad joke
which if i'm honest i'm kind of bummed
that i didn't think of
hopefully some more dad jokes pan out
this one kind of petered out at the end
all right so i'm going to change this to
github
notifier it says carefully you have
unsaved changes so i'm going to click
save changes because i want that so
we want a thing called github notifier
in general
so again what's happening here is that
this is building a webhook
handler so when you post to it it sends
a message
into the general channel now this is
important to note
this is different from what we saw at
github github made the request to the
handler
this handles the request both called web
hooks
but therefore because we have both sides
of this we should just be able to
connect them
right in fact
it looks like the only thing i can do is
just copy this webhook url
so and really that's the webhook handler
url
i'm going to go ahead i'm going to click
this learn more up here because
let's let's assume that we didn't know
what we were going to do with this i'm
going to click up this
at this learn more
and it talks about some things that we
could do and it says
can't really use web hooks can use web
hooks here's github that's great i'm
going to make this a little bit bigger
for all of us uh it's talking about
making a web hook oh look
it's changed already so before it was
it's under integrations now
so already see these notes have changed
a little bit that's fine so there's the
captain hook joke
for get updates um let's see
let's keep on scrolling well this looks
important
to make a web hook message display
messages properly it's really really
really really really
really important to the caps there got
me uh that you append slash github to
the end of it yes like
five real is important okay so it's
telling us to go over to our github
settings like we had done before
and uh put the slash github on there so
let's let me get back to that let's get
back
here we are here is my github uh
repo and i'm going to leave this old
this old web hook in place so let's
let's go back into our web hooks here
and i'm going to add a new one so you
can have multiple web hooks
doing different things and let's do that
let's just explore what that feels like
so i'm going to add a new web hook
and i'm going to paste uh before i
copied right i copied from that discord
i
clicked the copy url button so i have
that there except then i copied the help
so that's not good
let's not use that let's go back to the
discord
and i'm do this copy webhook url
so now it says copied in the clipboard
i'm going to come back over here and i
am going to paste
and wow that is a long url and i need to
do something i was reminded something
like
five times oh right really really
important to say slash
github at the end there we go
now this handler is unique to me so that
you can tell that this is
whatever this is here this yours is
going to look different than this this
is this is my
specific user probably my specific
channel all encoded in there and i've
added slash
github at the end and the content type
in those notes i saw that it said
application json
and what's nice about of course having
two different web hooks is we can do
whatever we want here i'm going to click
just send me everything
everything that happens let's go ahead
and send it
and i'm going to click add web hook
okay and fingers
crossed i am going to
unstar the event and i'm going to start
oh
i heard a little discord beep i think we
got i think we did it
i'm going to go oh that was that reveal
wasn't as exciting as it could have been
because i wasn't here but look
there we go a new star was added by
craig s dennis and there's my little
that little uh
avatar of mine it's working
i think it could probably be a little
bit more celebratory but
check us out we wired up two completely
separate services
just like that pretty cool right we set
out to do basically
just what we wanted when someone stars
our repo everyone in the general
channel there will be able to see it and
they can celebrate along
we saw how the the nomenclature was kind
of interesting right like we saw
how both services github and discord
call it a web hook
one is the pushing side and the other is
the handler side it's a little confusing
isn't it
but what discord is doing by putting
that trailing slash github
is specifically formatting that
information that's pushed across from
github
it understands what is sent from github
and has specific formatting for discord
i don't know about you but i think for
stars
i'd like to see it more sparkly give me
some more emojis in there at least you
know really celebrate
so in order to do that we'll need to
handle that github request
ourselves and turn it into the format
the discord's expecting
that sounds like a good idea let's
get ready to write some code there goes
our no code streak
why don't you get up take a breath of
fresh air
give those coding muscles a stretch and
be ready to come back
and dive into some code
[Music]
we've got our github event notifications
broadcasting to our discord channel
and we're feeling pretty good about what
we were able to accomplish with just
a little bit of configuration but we've
decided that we want to make things work
a little bit differently than the
default
this is a very common scenario
and a good look at why sometimes you
can't solve everything with no code
solutions
there are often specific tweaks that
your customers would like to make
that aren't necessarily exposed
let's make our tweak let's make it so
that when someone stars our repo
we write out some emojis and show a big
picture of our code's newest fan
now in order to do this we'll need to
write a handler
i've written the boilerplate or the
beginning common bits of the code for us
already
it's available in the repo before we
dive in
i want to take a quick moment here to
talk about some of the possible
challenges that we might
start to encounter as we start
developing on our local machines
in order to get things up and running
here i'm going to be using
a lot of tools now depending on where
you are in your coding journey
some of these tools might be completely
unfamiliar
i want to assure you that it is okay for
it to feel overwhelming
we've all been there setting up these
tools is a one-time thing but it
definitely is a hurdle that i don't want
to minimize
i've seen this frustrate folks to the
point of giving up their coding journey
please
don't give up you're doing great and you
will make it through this
ask for help and remember all of us have
been through this
i've included instructions for
installation for all of the tools that
we'll be using here shortly in the notes
please remember that you can pause me
for as long as you need to get things
working
all right let's do this the first thing
that we're going to need to do is get
this repository from github
onto our local machines and the way you
do that is by clicking this
code button as you can see
there are several ways to get a hold of
this code
you could even download a zip if you
wanted to however
i'm going to suggest that we use git to
do this but
like you see here you don't have to so
i'm using a mac and i'm going to start
my terminal so i'm going to do that by
pressing command space
and typing terminal on windows this will
be either your command
prompt or your powershell so at the
command prompt
i'm going to make sure that i have get
installed i'm going to type git
dash dash version there we go and as
long as something comes back
you're all set if not you'll need to
install git there are instructions in
the teacher's notes
git is a powerful version control
software which lets you and your fellow
developers
make and document changes to files now
using git is unfortunately out of the
scope of this course
but i highly recommend learning it i've
shared links in the notes for where to
pick up this crucial
collaboration tool it makes things like
we're about to do
super convenient so i'm going to
navigate to where i'd like to store this
code this is of course a personal
decision
i keep a code directory or folder right
off my home directory
which is represented by this tilde and
using in unix land
so i'm going to change directories or cd
into that directory and it's called code
and i'm going to make
a new directory here called courses i
like to store
the tutorials and courses that i take uh
the code for them i
i i store them in a in a place called
courses so i'm going to say make
der mkdir courses
so back at github i'm going to choose
that i want to get this using https i
could use ssh if i wanted to but i'm
going to use
https typically i do use ssh this is
up to you if you have it set up this is
something you need to do if this is your
first time doing it you won't need to
set anything up to make this work
so i'm going to copy this url here i'm
going to click this
and i go back to my terminal i'm going
to say git
clone and then i'm going to paste so
we've got that url there so i'm going to
click this
what this does is this pulls all a copy
of all of the code and puts it locally
on my machine here and so now that it's
here i'm going to change into that
directory so cd
web and i'm going to press tab webhooks
course here we go
and i'm going to open up this whole
directory in my
editor i use visual studio code and if
you don't yet have an editor i highly
recommend
this editor as well it's pretty great
it's free there's tons of plugins
there are installation instructions in
the notes so i'm going to type code and
then i'm going to press dot
awesome here it goes let me make this a
little bit bigger
the code that i want to draw your
attention to is over here in the code
directory so i'm going to click this to
open it
and then i'm going to look at this
express disk order this is what we're
going to work on
right now so we're going to open up this
express disk order and
in here in the js this has the
boilerplate code that i was talking
about
this is using a web server called
express
and the handler that we're going to
handle is a
a post from slash github and then it
will run this code we'll take a look at
this code here in a second
but basically it means if you make a
post
to this web server that's running here
this web server
at forward slash github it'll run this
code here this code will run
when a post happens but in order to run
this
we need to make sure that we have node
installed
so vs code has a built-in terminal
actually so let's go ahead and use that
so we're going to go to terminal
and new terminal and you'll see here
that in the future i can use control and
then tilde
nice and so now it's put me in the root
there so i'm going to go into cd code
and then i'm going to go into the
express disk order folder
awesome in order to run this server
we'll need to make sure that you have
node installed
i told you there are a lot of tools so
node is a javascript runtime that allows
you
to run scripts on your local machine
let's check and see if you have it
already so
i'm going to go ahead and type node dash
dash version
now as long as this first part here this
v
whatever is 10 or greater the code
should work as expected now if not
check the teacher's notes for how to
install node once you have node
installed you'll also have
npm installed npm is node's package
manager
and you'll find that it stands for uh
just about
anything i actually have quite a quite a
bunch of fun with that
uh let's just go to the page really
quick uh
so it stands for nice paintings mondrian
and uh what else does it stand for oh
does it not refresh every time
there we go nincompoops producing
methane
lovely plastic mustache okay there we go
so it stands for node package manager
but
it stands for a lot of things so what
i've done already is i've built this
package.json file
and it has in here some dependencies
and the dependencies will come in and it
will they'll they're going to be
installed for you
when we use npm so
let's install those things so we'll do
that with npm
install that will go and install
packages like express you know the web
server and it will also use axios
which is a library that we can use to
make our own post request because we're
going to post
to the discord url
we need to make post requests because
we're going to post to our discord
webhook
handler like right in here
so uh so it says axios dot post and
we're gonna post oh
that reminds me we're gonna need to uh
store this someplace because remember
that's that's private to you
it's your personal link and as you're
about to see
you don't want anyone getting their
hands on it if they just post to it they
could post in your channel and you don't
want that happening
so one way of dealing with this security
is to use what's known as an environment
variable
and what the code here is using this
process.m.discord webhook url
is accessing your environment variables
so what i've done is i've set things up
so that you can define
in a file named dot env and that's right
over here and that's
short for environment and you'll see
that you don't have one
right now because we just checked this
out right so what you're going to do
is you're going to want to copy this env
example so we're going to grab this file
we're going to uh
let's see i'm going to copy and then i'm
going to click this and i'm going to
click paste
right so i right clicked or two finger
clicked on a mac
to do that and i'm going to rename this
file now to dot
env dot env here we go and uh
in here you'll see that you need to get
a hold of your web hook url
so i'm going to go and grab that
from discord so back in my settings
remember in the
the channel under integrations under web
hooks i can view this web hook
here's my github notifier i'm going to
copy the web hook url
i'm going to come over here and i am
going to paste it and save
so now i have a env and this is this is
my own
private uh file uh and what's nice about
that is this code
uh can now be shared right like it's
it's code that
maybe anybody can run like so so i i was
able to give this to you and what made
it personal for you was you put stuff in
your environment variable
this is a common way to share code but
have the private information like the
stuff that's unique to you
hidden okay with that all set up
i think that we're ready to spin up this
web server so i'm going to write npm
start
and it says that is listing listing at
localhost and it's telling me i can
command click that let's go ahead and do
that
and thumbs up indeed we did it so we
have a local
web server running awesome whew
that was a lot of tools to install in
one video
now that we're all set up we need to
make it so that github points to our
local web server
uh-oh our local web server
it's not on the internet how can github
possibly see
it let's take a quick break and when you
come back
let's explore tunneling so that web
hooks can see
our local system we just got a local web
server all set up
and it's ready to handle events from the
github web hook
but we have a slight problem our web
server is local
only we can see it it's not on the
internet
and this is typically how you do
development right you develop locally
you get things working the way that you
want to
and then eventually you deploy your web
server to a public-facing url so that
the world can visit your masterpiece
but typically you only deploy after
you've worked through all your
challenges you don't deploy right away
now this makes for an interesting
challenge in creating web hooks
in order for a web hook to work we need
to be able to make a post request to a
public url now the good news is
there are a lot of tools and yes i'm
gonna have you install another tool
sorry but it's just one this time so
what this tool does is it opens up a
tunnel on your local machine
so that your application can be publicly
accessible from the internet
now this type of tool is handy also for
like if you want to see your application
in development like if you want to look
at your phone or your tablet instead of
just your local machine
it's pretty handy and it's quick to use
all right
let's open up this tunnel the tool we're
going to install is called
ingrock the n stands for network and to
grok something means to
understand it it's also a unix tool that
allows you to understand
unstructured data what ingrock allows
you to do is open up a specific port on
your machine
now if you recall our local server was
running on port
3000 so what we can do is open up that
port
to the internet i hope that you'll grok
ngrok here shortly so first things first
get ingrock installed now not to be a
broken record
but this page is bound to look different
in your future check the notes if you
have trouble following along at any
point
so there's a download section so uh
let's go in here
let's go ahead let's download it it's
free i'm going to download this for mac
os i'm sure
it will uh detect where you're at and
what you get back is a zip file that has
a command line executable in it so i'm
going to click that
and open it up and it automatically
opened up in my downloads
directory so go ahead and pause me and
try to
find where your download went mine went
into my downloads directory
so i'm going to go in my visual studio
code i'm going to open up another
terminal here this
you can do that with this little plus
here so here's another terminal
and i know that that went into my
downloads directory
so i can say cd
uh my home directory and then downloads
and then from here i can say in this
directory run
ingrock dash dash help we can just kind
of see what it does and
there's the different things that it can
do so
i use ingrock all the time so i've put
it in my path
and that lets me run it from wherever
i'm at check the notes on how to do this
it's totally optional
i will use the ngrok from my downloads
directory in these videos
but if you want to add it to your path
because you want to use it all the time
check the notes and you can get yourself
set up
okay so i'm going to go back to my other
tab
like i have three open you can type exit
uh there so i've got
the node i have the the server is
running and it's running on localhost
3000 and in my
uh other terminal here i'm going to go
ahead and do dot slash
ingrock and then you say what you want
to do so i'm going to open up an
http port right hypertext transfer
protocol
and i want to open it up on port 3000
and if i do this what happens is i get a
brand new
url and if i copy this i copied this url
and you'll notice that there's a there's
a https as well
which is pretty awesome you get an https
for free so i'm going to go ahead and
copy that one
or actually i could command click it
let's do that we'll command click it
and it's going to open up that webpage
and you'll see that this
this string of numbers if i did that i
could also open that up on my phone or
my tablet
and it would be working so
i totally had that hair do by the way so
because we can see this url
it also means github can now post its
payload to us
and we can process it so let's jump back
and let's take a little deeper look at
what's happening in that code in the
server.js
so let's get back into that code there
see if we can
get a little more real estate over here
i can't
unfortunately let's see maybe we can go
a little bit
lower there is that all right i think
that's all right okay
so we are going to get a post to slash
github
and it's going to uh it sets up a couple
things we've got this content and we
have this uh
hard-coded avatar url and it's going to
post
to our webhook url it's going to post
the content which is what we said here
it should say wav this is a
an emoji and i should say hi mom
and uh i like to always debug with my
mom whenever i can
and then uh we're gonna post and then
we'll get we'll send back a
a success message uh if it worked and if
not we'll send out an error here
well let's run it i'm going to copy our
ingrok url one more time just make sure
i've got that in the clipboard i'm going
to copy this
and i'm going to take that over to our
github settings right so let's get back
here's the githort github course i'm
going to go into the settings
head over to web hooks and
i am going to add a new web hook
and it's making me log in so i'm going
to use
i'm going to grant me grab my my
password here
okay
all right so we're going to add that web
hook
and again i'm going to copy that because
i copied my page my password
so i'm going to copy this link here
the ingrock i o and remember that we
have a slash github that we need to post
to
so let's go in here we're going to paste
let's get this trailing stuff off and
we'll say
slash github and we wanted to send json
because i think that's easier to work
with and
let's do again let's just select the
individual events we'll do a star
let's uncheck pushes we
are just interested when somebody starts
and we're going to go ahead and
add webhook
okay
so let's switch back to our node
server uh oh it said success it said
success does that mean that we got a
post already
uh don't switch
boom we got it so so as soon as you set
it up it sets one so there we go
hi mom and there's dr tyson amazed by
what we just did
so we sent a message from github through
our tunnel
to our local machine back out to the web
hook handler
awesome boom indeed dr tyson
we got it well kinda i mean we got the
starts of it right
so now we can iterate our development
until we get exactly what we want
so just like we saw with b ceptor i can
actually use
ingrock to see what was passed to us so
let's go to the ngrok
go back to the ngrok window real quick
and if i come i'm going to move this up
a little bit here
even a little bit more you can see that
there is a a post was made uh
to to our github from github so uh in
here there's this web
interface so if you follow this link by
doing a command click on it
you will see um that this is the
information that we got from github now
let's go ahead
let's make sure that it's working when
we get a start because right now
uh that just worked from the original
message i'm going to go to webhooks
uh i'm going to um
unstar and star i think i think we'll
get two yeah so you get one
every time you start every time you
don't start so there's a new start added
that was from one of the bots that we
were pushing before and then here's this
one
uh that we just did from getting a star
on the thing awesome
so it's working and if we look at our
ingrock inspector here
uh we can see that this is the message
that was sent and it was an action that
was created and this is nice right this
is we can see exactly what was sent so
we can we can
hang out in here and now i realize that
github also shows you this
and we could do this with b ceptor but
once you get in grok running this flow
is pretty much all we need right so
we can see that there's uh there's the
sender there's the avatar that we're
going to need to grab
and i'd also like to show the repository
name
right so let's take a look and see if we
can't find that too so the repository
name
ah this is great this would be awesome
here to say that the name of it so you
can either use this name or full name
so those are what we want to grab from
this json that just came in from the
post
so let's take a look at that real quick
so since we already have
the in our code
let's bring this back down here in our
code we already have this avatar url
defined here let's go ahead and let's
grab that from
the request how's that sound so we're
going to get rid of
this this hard-coded dr tyson
thing there and we're going to get from
the javascript object that's being
passed in here so we have the request
that comes in and on the request there
is a body
and i have it so that it is reading json
for us this this boilerplate
is reading the json so it knows about it
so that was in
dot sender right at the bottom there if
we look
if we look um we were in
uh down here in sender
we have this avatar url right so so
this is who started and this is their
avatar so i have this avatar url so i'm
going to use that
here so i'm going to say
recbody.sender.avatar
and it was underscored url
and now to make sure i got it i'm gonna
need to start and stop my server
and it's a little annoying right this is
a little annoying to have to start and
stop my server to make sure that it
works
but i will so ctrl c will get you out of
that and then i'm going to do mpn
start to run that again uh and now my
code is reloaded but i don't want to do
that
every time i don't want to stop i don't
want to control c and do stuff so
i know i said only one tool and you
don't really need this
but i think you're going to want this so
there's a tool called
nodemon that will watch your javascript
files and it will automatically restart
the server for you it's really nice and
i want you to have it
although i don't want to keep on
throwing tools at you uh but let's
i'm gonna show you how i install it uh
you don't have to use it so we're gonna
do npm
install dash uh or nodemon
dash g for global so after you install
this you can use it whenever that's what
the dash g means there and so now
that this has been installed we can say
nodemon start it kind of looks like it
says no demon or like nodemon
anyway so here we go and now you can see
that if i add this hi-mom
and i add some more and i click save it
will restart the server which is exactly
what we
want right you want to change every time
you save you want the server to be
running your latest thing it's a it's a
quick
rapid development thing that once you
get in the handle hang of it you will
love it alright so the surgery started
and back on the ingrock page i don't
know if you noticed this or not but this
is awesome there is also just like on
uh again there's a replay so you can
replay and you can actually even edit it
but i'm gonna go ahead and click this
replay oh there we go
okay so there we go hi mom there's the
there's my avatar coming through so
so my avatar url is now there so now
that's a pretty big picture i love that
that feels great this is like this is a
new person who liked your code
great good feeling we're doing good
and we really say hi mom now right our
changes
our change is live so now what we need
to do
is we need to change the content
variable
okay so we need to we need to change
this content so instead of saying hi mom
we need to make this dynamic about who
who came in
let's do this let's i'm going to write
it to do here so
i'm going to write it to do so we'll say
to do
change the content
variable to contain the
re repository name
and
the github
username and
why don't you add some emoji flare so uh
you can you can explore if you want to
uh in in here uh
you can explore with you know there's
like rocket
right so there's a there's a rocket
thing that you can do so if you just
type colon and then the name of it
you can start seeing what it is that you
could do with emoji flare so
why don't you pause me and see if you
can complete this to do
so use the request from github to do
this right so you can look over
at your ngrok and see what's going on
there and make sure that you
change the content of this and then go
ahead and
do a replay and see if you can get that
content to be what
you're happy with when somebody starts
your repo
so give it a shot and when you're done
unpause me and i'll show you how i did
it
remember to use ngrok to see what the
request looks like and to replay it are
you ready
pause me
how'd you do i hope it went well and
don't sweat it if it didn't you'll get
this
so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna grab
the username
and that was in rec dot body
dot sender dot login
okay so and then i'm also going to grab
the repo name
i like to pull these things out just to
make sure i got them so we'll say
rec.body.repository.name
so the center is at the bottom and the
repository was up at the top there in
that request
and what we can do is we can use a
string template in javascript so we can
say
uh one of these back ticks like this
right so then we could say
dollar username
just starred dollar
repo name and this way
you could have other people uh set up uh
to their repo so you could share like
let's say we're in a community of
everybody who was
uh write some code together we could all
run this
uh and because this is our own private
discord url you could let other people
run it in their github
in their their discord webhooks or they
can post to this url
awesome so let's go ahead i'm going to
save this it's saved
and the server has restarted so
fingers crossed we're going to go back
over to
our ingrock and we're going to click
replay we heard the little discord go
and it says craig s dennis just started
the web hooks course
oh shoot i forgot my flare let's go back
let's see
i definitely think we need some tacos
can't have enough tacos so we got taco
taco
um how about
uh let's definitely do the rocket that's
one of my favorites rocket and i also
like tada
ta-da taco
and i will save and again
i'm going to come back and i am going to
replay
i heard the baboop and there we go oh
beautiful
so much flair awesome pretty smooth
workflow right
i hope that gave you a clear feeling of
what developing a web hook handler might
feel like in practice
we saw how not only can ngrok open up a
tunnel to your local machine
but it also provides the ability to
review and store what was posted
and it even allows you to replay it
really speeds up your development
process
now i'm sure you're probably wondering
well great but does this mean i have to
leave my
local machine on and of course the
answer is no
but you're going to need to deploy your
application so that github can reach it
now if you don't have an existing
application this
can definitely seem daunting you
probably don't want to spin up a heroku
instance
just to host this single endpoint that
seems like a lot of work
one of the solutions that has been
gaining a lot of ground
is the idea of a cloud function we'll
take a look at this here in a second so
that you can see how that feels
these make a really good solution for a
quick web hook handler
and i want you to get a feeling for it
as it's getting more and more
popular in this world but before we get
there
you my friend are due for a break that
was a lot of technology and a smattering
of concepts
i want you to take a break and let it
all soak in i'd love for you to make
sure that you can picture in your brain
the request from github coming to your
handler
and your handler doing what it needs now
in our case
it's posting to a webhook handler that
was already set up by discord
i'd also like you to take a minute and
realize that you can now run
any code at all when an event that
supports web hooks occurs
you can handle it that's pretty cool
isn't it now as empowered as i felt
before by the no code workflows like
ifttt
these possibilities are actually quite
limitless
now i could definitely make my dog light
up when i get a star
well check this out just like this
dog star keanu would get that one
okay so after your break let's swing
back and check out serverless cloud
[Music]
functions
[Music]
do
[Music]
okay we got our web hook written and
we're happy with it
but in order to run we need a public url
and
while our tunnel solves the problem for
development purposes
it's definitely not production ready now
we could
deploy our web server that we wrote and
host it somewhere there are lots of
providers that do that
and it's definitely getting easier to
deploy a web server but
even the server seems a little heavy
doesn't it we're really
just taking some values and quickly
doing our thing for a single request
type
it's hardly a web application well we're
not alone in this feeling
succinctly this feeling is do we even
need a server
could the project go without one could
this be serverless
there's a growing movement called
serverless and it tackles this problem
exactly
you don't need to worry about the server
someone else will handle it for you and
it will scale
both up and down for you now this
scaling both directions
is referred to as elasticity
function as a service or fast is the
idea
at the core of serverless basically you
write a function and you follow the
specific parameters
and the provider handles all the routing
responses and scaling
all of the big cloud players have some
sort of version of this
and typically the executions are free
until you hit a certain threshold
and even then you only pay for when the
function executes
this can lead to tremendous cost savings
also because there's only ever one
function
it makes the code very easy to read and
understand
so it's kind of like take me down to the
paradise elasticity where the fast is
cheap and the code is pretty
oh won't you please take me i warm oh
yeah
is that that too much that i really axel
wrote to the occasion there
i guess we can probably just slash that
part out later okay
fine no more pawns in roses
i thought you should have a taste of how
the serverless development feels and so
i went ahead and got the solution all
coded
up and ready to deploy there are a lot
of serverless providers to choose from
but one of my favorites to get up and
running quickly
is netlify now standard warning is in
effect
this flow that we're about to do is
bound to look a little bit different
netlify is always adding functionality
and another thing that i want to point
out here before we dive in
this is totally optional you don't need
to do this i
totally won't be offended if you just
watch me do this so
i've signed up for a netlify account and
i use my github account
and i'm going to head to their docs
really quick and they're right here in
the header
docs now what i want to install
is the cli or command line interface
which allows us to run commands from our
command line for netlify so let's go
ahead let's click this let's get started
so here's some great information on it
and we're going to go ahead and install
it and we're going to install it with a
g which makes it go globally okay
so that means that we can use it
wherever so i'm going to come in here
and i'm going to run this right from the
root of the directory it doesn't matter
where we do it because we're going to do
it
globally so this will install the
netlify
package and what this will do is we'll
here and shortly what we'll do is we'll
authenticate and it will allow us to do
actions on netlify
on our behalf it's super powerful
it's great you hardly ever actually need
to leave your
uh your command line anymore kind of you
just hang out in this editor
uh i think you're gonna love it okay
we are all set up here so uh again
like i said i had already started uh
porting this code
over uh and first oh let's let's log in
first so if we
if you do netlify space login
i'm already logged in but uh what will
happen here i'll switch my account so
that you can see
that i go through the same thing that
you do so i'm going to say switch my
account
and i am going to log into a new account
and it's going to pop up here and it's
going to say authorize this application
and
this is okay to do this what we want to
do we want to authorize that cli
awesome so uh now we can you can also
revoke it anytime from
the screen here inside of netlify after
you're logged in
all right here we go we are logged in to
netlify i'm going
to take a look at this directory here so
this is the netlify
discorder open that up and under
functions
discorder there's a file called
discorder.js
this is very very similar to the local
code that we had just looked at the
express code
there's a couple things that are a
little bit different uh the first thing
that i want to point out is that this
function
is asynchronous and you can tell that
because it says async
and what that allows you to do is then
later await
so you can see here that when this axios
remember this is what we're using to
post
to discord uh this returns what's known
as
a promise and it's a promise that in the
future there will be a value
and we handled this differently when we
were not in an async function and
let's just take a look at that real
quick so if i open up
the express disk order and i look at the
server you'll see that i did
axios dot post and then down here i used
a dot
then and i got the response back and
then i played with the response right so
this is a
a function that's getting the response
back but uh this this function when it
was declared is not
asynchronous and it's using a request
and a response remember that so it's
using the
request and we were able to pull things
off of the body
uh before so we're using rec.body and it
was a already a blown up object
um so just just remember that's a little
bit different so again this is using
this is uh using a promise and it's
using the then pattern
where what's different over in netlify
is we are
using an async method which means that
we're able to
do something like this where we can say
await now instead of
it coming through in a then function
this pauses
and waits and then goes here to go rest
so it's actually runs
synchronously or it appears to run
synchronously right
and uh what makes this different is
before we were catching it we were doing
a then and then we were doing a catch on
the error
here we're using a standard javascript
try
and catch very similar uh
just a little bit different of a pattern
i know that that can hang some people up
so please
check the notes if you'd like to learn
more about asynchronous javascript
and the other thing i really want to
point out with the main difference that
i had to do here
porting these things over was uh before
remember it was
request and response this just has
events okay so
uh what this what's expected is the
response you just returned so i'm
returning an object that gives a status
code of 204 instead of returning a
response that's what express
had accepted expected and event is
basically the request object more or
less
and what you'll see here is event.body
is a string and in this case it's going
to be
a json string and we're going to parse
it into body so then the rest of the
code is the same so
i just made an object called body which
is what was on
the other request it's just a little bit
different but pretty much the same code
so this code we're going to go over
into netlify discord
we're going to code netlify discorder
right because we want to get our prompt
in the same place here
now this is using axios and this also
has a package json
and you'll see that it's got axial so
i'm going to go ahead i'm going to do an
npm install
and there we go um believe it or not
this is ready to deploy
so watch this this is awesome so we're
going to say netlify
deploy and we're going to send this up
to the netlife server so the way that
this works is
anything that's in this functions folder
here is going to become a serverless
function
let's do it it's going to ask it's not
configured to a site this folder that
we're in right now so we want to create
a brand new
site so uh with that that is what we
want to do
and uh here we go so it says team craig
dennis's
everybody with the last letter of s
knows what i'm feeling there
um so yes we do want craig dennis as his
team
all right so we want to make a unique
site name
so they suggested super cool site by
craig s dennis
uh let's try github
stars because that's what we're doing
right so you'll have to choose something
different because i'm gonna
take it and somebody else already took
it don't you hate this is how people end
up with like
github stars 1925. so uh
github starred
yes i got it so i've got github starred
and that's going to be
githubstar.netlifi app so
now it's asking what directory do you
want to publish and it's that uh
it looks like almost like an emoji but
it's a dot there it says like this this
current directory yes that's the
directory i want
and would you believe it but we just
pushed up
to a server a live server there's a
function that's running
and it's running so let's go i'm going
to jump in here into the admin side of
things i'm going to follow this link
so i click that logs link there here we
come
we are up we are published today and
let's drop out let's go take a look at
these functions this is one
lambda function is ready and it's down
here it's this function
and in here it whatever the function
would run so this is this is what the
function's name is so this is this is it
here live
whenever this runs the function log will
show any sort of console log that we
have pretty cool right
i do have one little bit of
configuration to do
we need to set an environment variable
for what our personal
discord webhook url is right so that
that code remember i'm still using the
environment variables
in that code so i need to i need to put
that environment variable here and
that's
under here it's
under settings and then it's under build
and deploy
here we go environment variables and i'm
going to say edit variables
and our variable name let's just verify
we know what that variable name
is
it's inside this discorder file here and
we called it
discord webhook url so
i'm going to pop that into my
environment variable here
and the value that we want you can get
that from discord
let's go let's grab that one more time
just to remind ourselves where that's at
so we're gonna click the settings here
integrations view web hooks github
notifier and i'm gonna copy the webhook
url
okay so i copied that come over to the
build
i'm going to paste that i'm going to
click save
now if i come
back to my function let's go ahead and
get that url again so
it says that it is running in
production so i'm going to grab that i'm
going to head over to our github
and i'm going to go in my web hook
course and in
the web hook course here under settings
under web hooks
let's go ahead and let's edit this one
right this is our local machine this one
that we were doing last time
it's not going to work because sometime
i'm going to shut my computer off i
swear one of these days
i'm not going to have it on all right
i'm going to grab my password
so it pays my password
and i'm gonna make sure that i have the
webhook url copied
and i'm gonna change that to be
uh that's not right that we don't want
the discord web app url
we want the the githubstar.netlifi
app new site on netlify so i'm going to
copy that
and i am going to paste that into my
webhook
there we go everything is still set i'm
going to update the web hook
i am going to get my discord
into a good state here we go let's start
this thing
oh i heard it so we got the new star
added from here
where is the one from netlify
what happened let's see if we can debug
it
so is this updated github started
now if i discorder
what's this this doesn't look like
i mean maybe we need to update the web
hook it didn't maybe didn't update
oh here we go here's some failed ones
let's take a look
so what do we get in response the url
argument must be of type string
received undefined
let's see if that's the same thing again
the url argument must be
of type string received undefined
let's see
so it doesn't like that avatar url
let's see why so we've got it's a body
sender
avatar url we're parsing the event body
i'm assuming that's what the 500 is uh
let's look at our
we can look at our logs though too let's
see if there's anything that happened in
the logs
uh it just says that it ran
i didn't get an error there
let's see one more time what that said
so let's make sure that it has a sender
with an avatar url sender avatar url
yeah it's still there sender avatar url
so let's do a console log
let's just show that off
let's say console.log event
dot body and then we'll do afterwards
we'll say console
dot log body okay so
uh and i'm going to now i made the
changes here so i need to push them up
publish that directory and see it's a
lot quicker the second time around all
right
and let's go replay that from
from github we don't want the delete one
that was the delete
right let's replay the one
let's do it let's uh
oh there we go now it's working i don't
know what that was
something silly but i wanted you to see
what you should see is that this should
update
there we go so see i can see i can use
console log here
to look at things i'm not exactly sure
what happened i think what i'll do is
i'll go back and watch this but
you don't need to do the console log
bits there but
that is how you deploy and debug
a function in this in this new world and
the good news is is that this function
is
free for 125 000
executions a month i don't think i'm
going to run into that limit but you
never know
this is a pretty killer repository oh
and while debugging with those handy
dandy console
log statements on production might not
be your style and it really shouldn't be
your style
uh you can actually run a local netlify
dev environment
check the teacher's notes for that i
hope that gave you a good test drive of
serverless functions
pretty neat right these functions are
especially handy for web hook handlers
and other one-off scripts
you literally could use a function just
like that to kick off
just about anything that you can imagine
that's a lot of power
now remember on top of being basically
free
this will scale both up and down with
load because that elasticity
is at the heart of serverless technology
i've added links in the notes to other
serverless or
cloud computing providers all right
so now i hope that you're feeling like
you've got a pretty
good handle on web hooks you understand
why they're
useful you know what they can accomplish
you can see how you can do just about
anything and you even understand when
you should use them
and really that win is anytime you want
to get notified of an external event
whenever you feel like pulling an api
check to see if they support web hooks
first
basically you're a pro and
i realize you might not feel like one
we've been focusing on just one event
now there are a couple of other
platforms that deeply embrace the
concept of web hooks
i've got something planned that will
really stretch your new web hook muscles
and i hope
it should give you the confidence and
most importantly the practice that you
need
take a quick break and then let's get
started on the final project for this
course so far in this course you've
picked up
the essential skills that you need to
make use of web hooks in your
applications
so i thought we'd apply those skills in
a large project
using completely different technology
than we used thus far
this way you can see how your skills are
transferable
when it comes to technology that fully
embraces web hooks
it's pretty hard for me to think of
anything else other than twilio now
if you've seen my courses before you
know that i am pretty obsessed with
twilio
when i saw that they used a video game
to educate developers i was like
i've got to work at this place freeze
frame record scratch
now i'm a twillion and i'm in the game
but really
i've loved twilio ever since i was
introduced to it i was at a javascript
conference in 2012
and someone had built a scavenger hunt
that you could participate in by just
texting a number and it would respond
with different hints
now not only was it fun i was also
impressed with how people were using the
text messages
to build interactivity you didn't need
to install anything you just text a
number and you were playing
it's a pretty incredible input device
text messaging
is just one part of the platform really
any sort of communication or engagement
that you want to have
twilio has an api for it the way most of
the products work is that you buy a
phone number and that number is yours
immediately you can use it to make calls
and texts
and you can program what happens when
people call into it or text it
people build all sorts of fun and
creative things on the platform
in addition to a completely
cloud-powered call center
i've seen a video game get modified live
through a text message
somebody built a smash mouth hotline
which plays that one somebody once told
me when you call it
was such a mean trick to give someone
when they ask for your number
there have been crisis lines that keep
callers numbers anonymous and routes to
an available person who can help in the
time of need
i even saw a kid built a fake snow day
alert message
he got in trouble you can build just
about
anything you can imagine and twilio does
most of this magic
through web hooks we talked a while back
about life cycle hooks this is the
concept where the flow of the
application allows you to hook into it
and the control is passed to you you're
responsible to respond with what the
application should do next
and that's the main concept for what
happens with incoming input to your
twilio number
a call or a text message right the
control of the application is passed to
you
via a web hook there are a ton of other
web hooks that allow you to control what
happens
at different times when different events
occur continually passing control back
to your web hook handlers
and because your handler is any public
accessible url
your code can be in any programming
language it just needs to respond
with what you want twilio to do next
twilio's
basically a web hooks playground there
are an impressive amount of them to play
with
there's a couple of reasons for that
first off twilio has been around for a
long time so there's been lots of time
to build these events
to hook into and to perfect that flow
and for another reason
remember when we talked about the
creator of the web hook concept
jeff lindsay well he was a twillion in
the very early days of the company i
found
i found that out researching the history
of web hooks and
it all made sense so i figure what
better place to show off your new web
hook skills
is there than twilio first we'll build a
simple affirmation text app to get your
feet wet
and then we'll launch into a larger
project that will take ideas from
callers
record them and text them to us all with
web hosts
right let's get started building this
web hook based application
in order to show off the twilio web hook
basics let's build a really
simple messaging application what we'll
build is an app
that responds to any text message with
you've got this
just to give our texters a little
confidence boost turns out those three
words go a long way when you really need
them
now in order to get started you're gonna
need a twilio account now don't worry
it's totally free twilio offers a free
trial and they give you more than enough
free credit to build
all of the applications in this course
if you don't already have an account
go ahead and pause me and follow the
instructions on the teacher's notes
after you get your free trial all set up
un-pause me ready standard
word of warning this is bound to look a
little bit different as twilio
is always improving things check the
notes for anything that might function
a little bit different all right i've
set up a free trial account too
so we should be having pretty similar
experiences so
there are a couple of restrictions with
your trial account which are listed
up here so you can send messages and
make calls to verified numbers
and messages and calls include a note
about this coming from a twilio
trial account so like when we send this
text message we get text messages back
it's going to say sent from your
twitter trial account now if you didn't
already get your free trial number go
ahead and do that so
uh let's get get a trial number go ahead
click that
that's going to give you one 203 that's
great i'm just going to
choose this number
and right away this number is all
mine uh with a paid account you could
get more we only need everything that
we're going to build here we just need
this one
phone number and it doesn't matter that
it has the trial message stuff on it for
what we're going to build all right
let's do it so remember what we're going
to do
is we're going to make it so that if
anybody texts this brand new number that
we just bought we're going to return
back
a nice affirmation so to do that
i am going to navigate to my numbers so
over here
there's these little three dots all
products and services and i'm going to
choose
phone numbers here and you'll notice
that there's this little pin icon
if you pin that it will make it so that
it's part of the menu so when you come
back in here you can find it there's
a ton of products i'm going to pin it
right now let's do that
so uh you'll see here here's the menu
now i've got this phone numbers thing
here so let's go into our phone numbers
and again this is our demo one my demo
one you have a different demo one and
i'm gonna click into that
and i'm going to scroll down on this
configure page you'll see voice and fax
yes you can actually send faxes actually
comes in handy i don't know if you have
a fax machine anymore
i don't i'm going to scroll down here to
messaging and you'll see it says
messaging when a message comes in
send it to this web hook via an http
post send it to this web hook and that
is supposed to return
the instructions that twilio is
expecting now the format that's expected
is twiml or twilio markup language
just like html renders your web page
twiml
renders your application so i'm actually
going to change this from webhook
to twimlbin a twiml bin is a handy way
to return these instructions
you don't need to spin up your own
server this is taken care of for you
by twilio so it's a serverless solution
so here i'm going to make one
so i'm going to do that by clicking this
plus button here so i'll say plus
so i am going to name my 121 bin so i
can find it later i'm going to call it
affirmation
now twiml is tag based
and case sensitive so i'm going to say
and all of them start with a response so
response
response okay so
we want to add a tag that sends back a
message and that tag is
actually message
and we'll say you got this
i'm going to drop a muscley icon in here
just to really get the point across
there we go
and then i'm going to close this message
tag awesome
and you'll see that there's some it'll
tell us whether or not we've got it good
it says this is good
valid messaging twiml so let's do it
let's go ahead we're going to click
create on this
and now you'll see messaging when a
message comes in go to this twiml bin
called affirmation return that
i need to remember to save the number
all right now
i'm going to pull out my phone and i am
going to text my number there
203 902
5283 and what i expect whatever i send
right
immediately it's going to send back you
got this so i'm going to say
uh i'm
having a hard time with javascript
and it says you got this you're right i
do got this
thanks awesome okay so that
is basically the hello world of
twiml web hooks and that's pretty
awesome right
it's a good use it's like when a message
comes in send it to this web hook
now remember this can be any programming
language or
tool that returns a valid twiml string
so you could return this from any web
application that you have existing
already
and this twiml bin that we used because
we didn't have a
server up and running it's a serverless
solution twilio's hosting it for us
and handling the scaling for us like we
don't need to worry about that at all
more of this on the teachers notes
pretty great right
we now have a way to respond to any
incoming message to our number
while we're currently only using a
static solution we could definitely
build a dynamic
handler that did whatever we wanted
this is like our handler that we use for
posting to discord and this could be
whatever you could dream up
and you can respond with a valid twiml
string to continue the application
we'll get to some more local development
here in a second but first
i think we should explore a low code
tool used to
build complex serverless workflows okay
my next idea for an app
is a little meta i would love to have a
call in line where anyone could call and
describe their ideas for cool web hook
implementations
i love hearing all your ideas and i find
that when i discuss things out loud
it greatly increases the likelihood that
i'll get it done
so let's do that let's build a hotline
that prompts the caller to record their
idea
and once the idea is recorded let's
transcribe it and then text it to
ourselves
we took a look earlier at some no code
solutions that were powered
under the covers by web hooks twilio
provides a low
code serverless solution that allows for
rapid development and prototyping of
applications
it's called studio and like most no code
or low code tools
you'll find that you can build a lot of
solutions just by dragging some objects
around
let's build the first part of an
application using studio we'll make sure
to keep our eyes out
for web hooks hey future you
this is for sure going to look different
you'll find that almost all
no code tools rapidly iterate on their
ui daily to make things more quick and
clear
and i'm always pleasantly surprised when
i open up studio
i'll update the notes on any changes
that might have occurred since
right now in my timeline all right let's
do this
okay so we are in our twilio console
i'm on the phone number page currently
and i'm going to jump over to studio so
that's this
these three little dots over here and i
am going to scroll down
into runtime and i'm going to choose
studio and i don't want to do that
scroll again so again i'm going to pin
that so that shows up
in my little menu here so i'm going to
go to studio
and i'm going to click this create a
flow button because that's what we're
going to do we're going to create a
brand new flow
so let's do that i want to call this
flow idea catcher
and we'll say next and you'll see
there's a bunch of templates that we can
use but let's just start from scratch
we have a pretty straightforward way of
doing this so let's go ahead let's just
go
next that looks like the dork that
starred my repo
so this here is called the canvas
and what you do is you drag widgets onto
it so
let's see when someone calls we should
tell them what we are expecting them
to do so i am going to grab this
say and play because i want it to say
what we want them to do so i'm going to
drag this over
and we're going to drop it right here
and
now that it's out here i can click it
and what will happen is over here these
uh properties will change
so this say widget allows us to do text
to speech so um
i could also give it an audio file if i
wanted to that's in here i could make it
play a message but we're going to have
it say a message
we'll do text to speech so let's see i
wanted to say hello there
um i'd
love to hear your
wonderful idea
tell me about it after the beep
all right so these other fields down
here they are optional but they're here
let might as well fill them out right so
uh let's make it english
and let's choose a voice i'm gonna
choose
uh kindra neural
so um this is from amazon poly all these
voices are from amazon paulie and this
is kindred neural so it's kind of got
this fun
that those days of like those robo
voices are gone
i remember when when uh text-to-speech
first came out and it couldn't even say
cheeseburger was like chas
emerger so i'm calling kendra i'm going
to leave her there
and we can make it loop a certain number
of times so that
is feeling pretty good i'm going to
click save to update the widget
and we want this to be said when
somebody calls so what we're going to do
is we're going to drag from this trigger
note this is like a web hook right so
we're going to say
when an incoming call comes we're going
to go to this
here awesome and that's probably enough
to test isn't it don't you think so
uh the way that these works is you can
see that i made four changes but i'm
going to go ahead and i'm going to click
publish here so we're going to publish
the flow
it gives us a little bit of warning
ahead of time and now this is ready to
use so i'm going to go
into back to my number
and i am going to come into
my number and i'm going to scroll down
here and so under the voice and facts
section
so when a voice call comes in when a
call comes in
we want to use a studio flow and we can
choose our flow of idea catcher and
click save
awesome now i am going to call
that number and i'll put it on
speakerphone here
you have a trial account you can remove
this message at any time by upgrading to
a full account
press any key to execute your code
here comes kendra i'd love to hear your
wonderful idea
tell me about it after the beat
so there's there's kendra telling us
about the beeps so that's awesome right
we got that up and running
very easily going through a web hook and
again that's
really rendering twiml behind the scenes
it works so now here's the trick that
flow that we built
is actually a web hook handler it
actually has a url
that little menu this little like
selective flow it's kind of hiding it
from you but it really is just a url
so what's really happening is when a
call comes in and twilio posted this url
our flow returns twiml in this case it's
the say twiml verb which is very similar
to the twiml that we wrote to send the
message
but the low code solution has that
hidden away now this is
very common in these low code solutions
they abstract away the code generation
and
all the web hook handling okay
so next we want to record what our
callers say so let's go back to our flow
so i'm gonna jump back into studio so
i'm gonna click this idea catcher and
get back into our flow here
so now we want to record so i'm gonna
drag out this record
voicemail we'll drag this out here
awesome
and let's take a look at its settings so
if i click onto it
we can see that it will stop recording
after five seconds
uh or you can make it stop on a if
somebody press the key
oh and uh 3600 that's 10 minutes
all right so that's an hour uh 3 600
seconds is an hour
um and that's more than enough even for
chatty folks who have very uh detailed
ideas
like myself very chatty uh okay cool so
uh
we also can transcribe the audio to text
we want that for sure
so i'm gonna click that on and look at
this
we have a transcription callback url
i know what that is that's a web hook
that is a web hook isn't it
so but what is actually gonna happen
when that transcription comes i i know
that i could go up here i could probably
go to this help here and figure that out
but if there was only a tool that we
could use that would just allow us to
put some random url there so that we
could see the results so we could
capture
what it was sent wouldn't that be nice
wait a second
there was something that we used earlier
wasn't there do you recall what it was
you want to try and do this yourself
if so go ahead and pause me and get a
web-based url in here
that we can use to see what values are
posted to it
are you ready you can do this pause me
okay ready how'd you do so the tool that
i was thinking of
was b ceptor so i'm going to head over
there really quick jump over to b
cepter again and
i'm going to create a new one called
recording because that's what we're
looking at right we're looking at this
recording thing here
um and we have that up and running so
now we know that we have this b
ceptor url so i've got this i'm going to
copy this
i'm going to come back over here and in
the transcription url i'm going to
paste the recording and i'm going to
make my own thing up here we'll
say transcription and
let's see uh do we want to play the beep
yes we definitely want to play a beep
because we said that right
um and we also have a recording status
call back i think we just need the
transcription right now right we don't
we don't really need to have to
to know when a recording is available
but look there's another web hook
all right so i'm going to click save and
then i want to connect
these two together so it says when audio
completes we want it to go to this one
so you can see that there's if you had
more here you could choose different
things to happen when
different transitions happen in each of
these widgets okay
so an incoming call is going to come
it's going to say hello there it's going
to record the voicemail and that
voicemail
should be sent to our place so i'm going
to click
save and i'm going to click publish and
now
i don't need to go update my number
again because it's already set to the
the flow right it's already set to this
flow so it should be working now so
if all is working as planned when i call
this
number again when i call my number and
leave
a message we should see a web hook
kick off here let's do it you have a
trial account
you can remove this message at any time
by upgrading to a full account
press any key to execute your code
hello there i'd love to hear your
wonderful idea
tell me about it after the beep yeah so
i have this idea where i'd like to
set up a call line where people could
call in and
record their ideas that's my idea
now hopefully i hung up and hopefully we
should see here in a second we should
see
our message has been recorded and it's
being transcribed right now and when the
transcription's done we should get
pinged over here
if all is working i'm trying to be
patient
there it is so we got a post to
transcription so i'm going to take a
look at that
so i click this and uh it's in the new
format let's scroll this down here we
can see we got a bunch of stuff that
came
in um
you can see i called that number oh
there's my number um
feel free to call i guess uh and
uh here we go transcription text so it
says yes so i have an idea where i'd
like to set up a call line where people
call and record their ideas yeah that's
my
that's pretty great but that's exactly
what i need so i need that transcription
text field that comes across that's
submitted
to my web hook i need that transcription
text that's what i need
awesome so now that we've got a web hook
event we could write
any sort of handler that we want we
definitely now have the
message has been transcribed event we
can do whatever we want with that event
we could very easily send that text
to discord now to complete our app we're
going to have to have this event send a
text message
now i'm excited to show you this as it's
super common to want to send a text
message
from your web hook handler there are so
many when this one event occurs
text me about it there all those ideas
are out there and they're just waiting
to be fulfilled
so let's develop this solution locally
using the local development tools that
we learned about earlier
we now have a transcription webhook
event that's happening and we saw in
bsepter what the format looked like and
we
saw what we wanted we are ready to
handle it we are going to text that
transcription to ourselves
doesn't seem like that big of an
application does it now
i could spin up a whole web server to
handle this request
but that sure seems like a lot of work
for a simple little application
do you remember this feeling from before
now we solved it
by using a serverless function on the
netlify platform
because this sort of one-off handler is
very common
twilio also provides serverless function
capabilities
what do you say we get one of these
serverless handlers up and running to
send our text messages out
guess what i'm going to ask you to
install some tools but they're super
handy and should be pretty quick
so the first thing i'd like for you
install is the twilio
cli or command line interface this is
very much like what we installed for
netlify
it will let you authenticate and send
commands to twilio from the comfort of
your own terminal
i love it so if you're a homebrew user
on a mac
you can install things using brew check
the teachers notes for that
we're going to use npm to install it so
we're going to say
npm install twilio dash
cli and we're going to do this with a g
which means
it's installed globally and we can run
it from wherever we need
cool uh and now we're going to do uh
much like we did with uh nullify we're
going to say twilio login
and this is going to ask us for our
account sid
or a string identifier for our account
for our twilio account so let's open
that up
uh let's jump in to
here let's go back to um
the home the console dashboard
so your account sits here there's a
little copy button here so i'm going to
click that
and copy that i'm going to pop back over
to my my terminal
paste that there and then we will go
grab the auth token which is a secret
token that you should never let out you
and you can get rid of it and i will get
rid of it later in case mine
ever ends up showing to you here but you
don't want to let that out that's a
secret
uh secret so i pasted uh there we go
and i am going to call this my
i'm going to call it my webhook account
i'm going to call webhooks
awesome the cli supports plugins and one
of my
absolute favorites is the serverless
toolkit we're going to
use it to set up and deploy our function
so let's go ahead and install it
now this is in the notes if you uh want
to copy and paste this
but you would do twilio plugins
install and then at twilio
labs and plug-in
dash serverless
and if everything is working as planned
you should be able
to write twilio serverless and get some
response back
awesome so there are the things that we
can do so
i am going to create a new
new twilio serverless project
and in this directory we're at up here
so there's a directory called code
and i made one called twilio there's
some light changer code in here that you
can look at later
um just kind of a little uh added bonus
here
for you so let's go let's jump into that
that directory so we're gonna go cd code
twilio
and then inside of this uh directory
here what we're going to do is we're
going to make
a brand new serverless
twilio serverless project and we're
going to use
the serverless plugin to do that so
we're going to say twilio
serverless colon init
and then you name it so let's call this
ideacatcher right because this is the
thing that we're gonna write
to um we're gonna we're gonna post to
this and then we're gonna make this
thing text
text to us so we'll do dash dash empty
uh there's lots of if you don't uh if
you don't specify empty there's a
um like we saw with the studio there's
lots of templates that you can use
i think we're going to start from
scratch because i think it's clearer in
the direction that we're headed right
now
so this is preparing a new directory so
it'll be all ready for us
and let's go ahead after it gets the
we're gonna go over into idea catcher
now
so uh you'll see up here there's this
twilio and we have idea catcher
here and let's take a look at what it
added it added some stuff for us
awesome so you'll see that there's a
folder for functions and there's one for
assets
um let's go ahead and let's make a new
uh file in this functions here so
i am going to click this little plus
button here to add a new file into this
directory
and i'm going to call it send text.js
all right this is the standard
boilerplate
that you'll need uh it's in the
teacher's notes too if you want to just
copy that so
exports.handler we're gonna write a
function called handler
and it takes a context an event object
and a callback all right and
we will make a function there so
callback is how you complete the
function
and it's important because of that
asynchronous nature of javascript
you can complete the function anywhere
really so
just to make sure that we got things
working i'm going to
call it now it's a standard node
callback function so that means that it
takes its first parameter
is any sort of error that occurred and
we're not going to
be expecting any errors with this and
we'll debug we'll just do
my typical hi mom awesome so
so the tool kit allows us to run our own
functions locally so that we can test
them so let's spin that up so to do that
you do twilio serverless
start awesome
and you'll see that it now says there's
a function available on localhost
3000. if i go ahead and i click that i
got hi mom
hi mom how you doing mom all right and
you'll see in the logs i've got a 200
and it made a get request
to send test excellent now
this server that we have up and running
is hot reloadable
just like we saw with nodemon or nodemon
this means that you can make a change
and it will be applied without you
needing to restart the server so let's
let's add a little console log here
we'll say console.log
we're going to be sending a text here
sending text
awesome so now if i go and i refresh
my mom page again i did a command r
there or ctrl r to do a refresh and if
we look back
uh we'll see that the console log popped
out here and again another 200
awesome without needing to restart
totally speeds up the development cycle
speaking of which
let's get to quickly developing okay so
okay so we need to have
our studio flow post to our
server uh oh our machine is local
we're going to need to have some way for
our flow to be able to see our local
server
do you remember how we did that before
want to pause me and see if you can
somehow get a public url for this
function
without deploying it okay
pause me and see if you can remember how
to open up the tunnel remember you can
go back
and it's okay if you totally didn't
drock it the first time
ready pause me
all right how'd you do so i was talking
about in grok to open up our tunnel so
i'll open up a new terminal here with
the plus
and i'm i'm gonna run that again that
was in my downloads directory
uh my downloads directory and it's in
grok there we go
so ingrock http
3000 right so that was running on port
3000.
there we go and so now we'll see we have
this uh
wild looking url i'm going to click that
open it up and it's not for that it's
for a slash
send text right so
isn't it called syntax
send oh i wrote i called it send test
but it should be send text let's fix
that
so if you were following along like i
hope you were you probably did that too
so you can right click and choose
rename and you can call this send
text i don't know what happens if you do
that does it restart
look at that it restarted with a new
thing called syntax i didn't have to
restart the server
awesome so it's now called sendtext
and uh if we're we're up here
i now have this wonky url
ngrok url that's up and running that
gets the syntax
so now the studio flow can see it so i'm
going to grab
that url and i'm going to go back to the
flow
so over here studio
i'm going to get back into my idea
catcher
and on the record voicemail we had left
the b
ceptor url and now we're going to paste
our
in drock url there awesome so i'm going
to click
save and i'm going to publish
and we'll call you have a trial account
you can review this message at any time
by upgrading to a full account
press any key to execute your code
hello there i'd love to hear your
wonderful
idea tell me about it after the beat
so here's my idea i want to build an app
that gathers ideas from people and then
texts it to me awesome so let's jump
over now i've hung up let's jump
over and watch it come in we should see
a post
to send text here in a second as that
transcription happens
boom there it is awesome and if we go
over to our ngrok
we should be able to open that up and
see that
the message came through all right so
what we were looking for
is transcription text here we go here's
my idea
i want to build an app that gathers
ideas from people and then text it to me
that's pretty good isn't it pretty cool
okay so let's make sure that we can
access that so uh
in our code where we're sending the text
um the way that those values come across
is they're on this
second object here called event so
we'll say let's do one of these we'll
say transcription
and that was event dot
transcription text
now do you want to hear me call back do
you want me to take that time to call
back or
is there some other way i can do that so
this is
the awesome flow that happens right so
i'm going to go back now i'm just going
to replay this
and we sent that text again and now we
should see
in my console log right if i switch back
over my console log but you see
there's the transcription thing and
there it is
we did it awesome we got the twilio cli
installed and all set up
this will let us interact with our
account and it also has a plugin
that allows us to quickly build
serverless functions
we got our local server all up and
running and opened up a tunnel using
ngrok
we're now able to handle the incoming
web hook request
we were able to get access to the
information and now we can also replay
those requests
that was quite a bit of work nice job
recalling how to get all those things
working together
now this what we just did is a very
common flow that you'll be doing the
more that you develop web hooks so it'll
only get more familiar
as you progress why don't we both take a
real quick break
i know i need some water when you come
back we'll wrap up the handler side of
the code
and then we'll deploy this function to
the cloud so we don't need to keep our
local machines running all the time
enjoy your well-deserved break you're
doing great see you soon
[Music]
okay let's write our handler bit we're
gonna write some code
that text you the transcriptions when
they arrive let's do this
all right so i am able to get the
transcription
uh that's being passed being published
from that web hook we're able to get the
transcription
back and so now we
want to text it so the context
object here is very handy it has a handy
way to get access to the javascript
helper library so what that does
is gives you an authenticated client so
we're going to say const
client equals context
dot get twilio client
now here's the thing we need to
be authenticated locally so we're going
to need
to provide the toolkit our official uh
account set an auth token so i'm going
to jump
into this dot env file here so see it's
the
this is this file label.emv and we have
two
uh things here in this already and i'm
just going to grab
again from from the console i'm going to
grab
my account sid
and you'll see and starts the ac and
this of course might look a little bit
different
as as the flow goes check the notes um
and i'm going to go and grab
my auth token and i'm going to come in
here and i'm going to paste it and i'm
going to make myself a note
to cancel that because i just showed you
my auth token
and that is dangerous because now you
could log into my account here and do
things on my behalf
because you know what that auth token is
so this magic.en file in
the serverless toolkit world what this
is is our environment variables
so they will be uh exposed uh actually
on that context object that
that we were seeing so we're going to
need a couple of things we're going to
need uh
my actual phone number right my phone
number that i wanted to text
which is 501 503
4610234
please don't call me too late at night
all right so there's that
and i'm gonna put in my twilio number my
this this twilio number that i have here
and again
what is my twilio
number my twilio number is right here
that's my trial number i'll grab this
and paste that here awesome i'm going to
save my emv file
and now we can use those so i'm going to
jump back into the syntax
and we're going to under this sending
text what we'll say
is well let's move let's move this back
up too all right so the client
it has access to all the resources so we
can do client.messages
and then what we want to do is we want
to create a new message and
what we'll do is we will pass in some
values
and so we're going to send a message to
me
or to you right so whatever we put in
there for phone number
uh that's what we're gonna do and then
we're gonna text that from our
trial number right so we'll say context
dot trial number now or not
twilio number um the reason why
this is working is that number should be
verified right so that phone number that
we put in i'm in trial mode i verified
with my phone number so that's why it
will be able to text it
so we have to from and we have body
helper messages are a little a little
tint sometimes so the body that we want
is we want to say that there was
a new idea that came in right and then
we just want to kind of grab
what we did before we got the
transcription text right so that here's
the new idea
so that's the body of the message seems
pretty good
maybe you know what we should do we
should also just just drop drop one of
those in there so if i i'm gonna
pop a pop of bulb in there
like that my burrito is a commonly used
emoji all right awesome it's time to i
think we're good i don't think we need
to say hi to mom anymore we'll
be sending the text um
now because we didn't put our personal
information
in here we could share this file file
with people and they could just
copy it and paste it right like we could
put this up on github and somebody could
just use it
in fact this is in the notes and you
could just use this code without
changing anything except for your
personal
environment number your phone number and
your twilio account your twilio number
are going to be different than mine but
the code is the same
so that's the power of environment
variables we
we have the same code in different
environments
now there's something tricky that we
need to be really careful about here
this create met this create call here
off of off of messages
this is asynchronous and we we saw this
before it's promise based
which means it provides functions to
return values or errors that will be
called when a value arrives or an error
occurs
which is a mouthful i realize so what we
want to do
is we want to call the callback only
after the message has been sent
otherwise it will just be over right
away right because this will just this
will finish it will be right over so we
need to put
the callback inside of the then
so what we're going to do is we're going
to chain off of the promise that's
returned so we're going to say dot then
and that's going to return a function
and it's going to return a function that
could just say
it will be the message right the message
that was created if it was successful
and uh what we'll do here is we'll do
the callback
and we'll there is no problems and we
will return
we can return a message we say sent
message
and uh that message object that comes
back has
an identifier as well so let's put this
on a separate line let's make that a
little bit
uh more friendly you can do that all in
one line like that
so let's see so we're going to have a
function
the then is going to return the then is
going to
expects a function that takes whatever
the returned value was if it was
successful
and then it will run this function and
that's when we want the function to end
we don't want it to end beforehand so
that's again this is that asynchronous
behavior
so we'll put a semicolon here at the end
and then we are going to come and we're
going
to catch this and uh
the catch also expects um if there is an
error um what's
the catch expects if there is an error
that you uh say something about so so
that this is a great place to do the
callback and just pass the error
into it okay
so let's walk this one more time so
we're going to use the context to get an
authenticated twilio client and it's
going to use
values from our environment our account
sid and our auth token to make sure that
we are
authenticated properly and then
it's going to uh for this authenticated
client it's going to make a new message
that's going to create a brand new
message and it's going to send it to
a phone number our phone number the
mobile number that you
you registered with and it's going to
uh send it from
our trial number right that's the trial
number that we have in there it's going
to
pass across the transcription text that
was on the event that came from the
request
and if that were successful we're going
to say the function is over and no error
happened and we'll just write something
else
something out it's not expecting
anything and if there is a catch
if there is a problem we are going to
call that callback with the error
we could put some logging in here too
why don't we do that
we'll say console.log
and we'll say we'll just do a
sent message and we'll do message.sid
and again that's a string identifier and
if there is an error we'll do console
dot error and we'll say
uh-oh and then we'll output that error
cool or at least the string version of
that error awesome
okay i am going to clear things down
here
i have that saved let's run this locally
first since we were just doing our
development thing there i had stopped my
server
so again that's twilio server let's
start so that that will start the local
server here
um
i was in the wrong directory
that's what that means so i need to get
in my idea catcher directory and i will
run that again
uh those up and down arrows to get back
to the previous command so twilio server
let's start
all right here we go so this
uh is what was running before i still
have my n grok running
and my flow is still pointing to things
so
that means i should be able to go back
to
my um my in grok
and just go ahead and do another replay
and i should
receive a text message and look at that
sent from my twilio trial account
there's a new idea
and it gathers ideas from people and
text it to me
awesome cool so we have the text working
we
have done our local development flow
and now we want to be able to not have
to run this on our computers right like
we don't
we don't want to keep our computer up
and running all the time so
we're going to deploy it and the way
that we do that
is very very easily we say twilio
swerverless serverless deploy
and it's building up everything we need
here and you'll notice
uh that what it's going to do is it's
going to take the the name of our
project
and put some extra stuff at the end to
make it unique so it's got this little
four digit number and it's got this dot
dev because that's the environment that
you are in so
by default it puts you in the
development environment so
let's go ahead it's deployed
believe it or not this is up and running
we could we could actually hit that but
i'm just going to grab this
and i'm going to pop back over to my
flow
and jump back in here you feel my flow
and i'm going to go into record
voicemail and i am going to
now the transcription url is an actual
real live hosted elastic in case i get a
whole bunch of ideas which i hope that i
do
i'm going to click save and that is
publicly accessible is now running on
the server
and so the final test
let's go ahead and give our number a
call
you have a trial account you can remove
this message at any time by upgrading to
a full account
press any key to execute your code
hello there i'd love to hear your
wonderful idea
tell me about it after the beep uh yeah
i have an idea
to make my dog lamp light up in morse
code whenever i receive a new idea that
gets transcribed
wouldn't that be great and i should
just about any second now i should get a
message
with a very strange idea
about sending morse code over a dog lamp
um i think i might actually write that
there got it in
it transcribed it exactly right awesome
we got it deployed and now we can shut
our computers off
now you might have noticed that uh this
was deployed to dev i know that we
talked about that but that's
you can also deploy to dev or staging
and then you can deploy to production
and that way you can develop
as a team in one place if you needed to
there's more on that in the notes if
you're interested in it but they're just
different environments so just keep that
in mind
you can have different environments
hosted uh up there
and uh with that we did it that is
awesome
did you see how the web hook skills that
you've picked up are fairly universal
it's pretty neat right i hope you're
feeling confident in your ability
first we were able to provide a handler
for the life cycle hook of an
incoming text message to our number we
did this with a static twiml bit but
remember
this is a web hook as long as we
returned valid twiml
we could do anything we didn't end up
using the body of the text message that
was sent to us
but we definitely could have like for
instance i could make it
so that if someone texted my number a
color it could change the dog color like
like for instance if i type
blue
there we go it responds to the incoming
message
and i deployed that it's a simple
serverless function it's in the notes
and it responds to an incoming text
message we also used a no code solution
to answer an incoming call and record a
message
what the tool did for us was to was to
deploy and return the necessary twiml
code to render the application
as more and more of these no code
solutions start popping up
look for how they're making use of web
hooks you can impress your friends like
you could be like well actually that's
just a web hook
actually never say that never say well
actually it's it's not a good look
we saw how the debugging tools like
bcepter and ingrock worked to capture
what was posted from the web hook
the replay feature saves a ton of time
so i'm glad that you've got that in your
tool belt
and we also got to use another
serverless function
those things are awesome little snippets
of code that you don't need to manage
they're elastic meaning they scale up
and down
automatically and almost all of the
serverless providers give a
very generous free tier so until your
application gets very popular which it
will
you don't need to pay anything at all
these are great for
little one-off scripts like web hook
handlers you
did it made it to the end of this course
nice work
i hope you enjoyed yourself i i know i
did i hope you now have a ton of ideas
that you can't wait to implement with
web hooks remember
if you run out of ideas go explore some
no code automation sites like ifttt or
zapier there are tons of great ideas
there i can't wait to see what you build
make sure to let me know about it i've
spun up a number that's similar
to what we built together i'll use it to
capture your feedback on this course
i use the transcription web hook to add
your feedback to a google spreadsheet
i hope that you're proud of your new
skills ooh that reminds me
send them in
i have something pretty important to
talk with you about
something something serious
the power that you wield
is needed now
more than ever
we are living in some dark
dark times and most of our time is spent
online in virtual
worlds worlds that are governed by the
laws
of code somebody writes that code
you're going to write that code
you know a kid's uncle once famously
said
with great power comes great
responsibility
i guess that's just really a roundabout
way of me asking you
is the code that you write gonna be used
for good
or not it's your choice really
so i'm asking you to take a vow
i want you to write code that unlocks
hope
power and freedom for all of humanity
i'm asking you to become an operator i
want you to join our quest
i need your help to
[Music]
lying save the cloud
of course
we need your help to save
the cloud thank you thank you very much
thank you so when should i oh oh uh no
need to call us
we'll call you oh right right
i'm still waiting for them to call me
back they got tired of me calling and
calling to see if i landed it
those hollywood folks sure stick to
their principles i hope i get it because
i love that twilio quest game
have you played it yet it's super
addicting it has awesome content for
those just getting started and those who
have been there for a long time
it has a built-in dev environment fun
side quests like contributing to open
source
it covers javascript php and python and
there are new updates
all of the time and omg the original
soundtrack
also i've got a serious robo crush on
cedric he's super adorable
i can't recommend it enough and finally
if you enjoyed this course
please let others know about it i'm sure
they'll thank you for
hooking them up thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you real soon
[Music]
you